que faire face à la violence de certains
patients dans les cabinets médicaux
question encore sans réponse malgré
malgré le cap de la trentaine
d'incidents en un an franchissent
vendredi en Indre-et-Loire cette fois
c'est un homme qui a saccagé une partie
des locaux de SOS médecins à Tours et
menacé son personnel retour sur les
faits avec Aurélie Renaud
le patient arrive avec 20 minutes de
retard la secrétaire médicale trouve un
autre rendez-vous il peut revenir dans
trois heures l'homme se met en colère il
crie il saisit un panneau en fer et
menace la secrétaire dans la salle
d'attente une femme et sa fille de 6 ans
elle se réfugie dans le bureau l'homme
commence à détruire l'accueil du cabinet
donc dès que j'ai réussi à avoir la
maman et la petite avec moi on a fermé à
clé on s'est dit s'il donne un coup ici
on peut recevoir du verre il peut
peut-être passer à travers donc c'est
pour ça qu'on a préféré vraiment se
cacher derrière le bureau pour pas
attirer l'attention en fait c'est vrai
que la maman m'a dit il est peut-être
armé je me suis dit ce que je vais
rentrer chez moi est-ce que bah au final
ça c'est comme ça moi que ça va se finir
pour moi c'est vrai c'est question là
passent en fait dans le c'est
obligatoire
en quelques minutes l'homme brise une
porte vitrée et fait plusieurs trous
dans les murs au même moment trois
médecins et leurs patients sont eux
aussi dans les locaux barricadés car
aucune discussion n'est possible avec
l'agresseur malgré les tentatives d'un
des médecins aujourd'hui l'équipe
envisage le recrutement d'un vigile et
travail sur différentes solutions pour
pallier les agressions le Béaba avant le
matériel c'est d'être au minimum 2 dans
les locaux c'est jamais laisser un
médecin seul en consultation de dans nos
locaux il y a six mois ici un autre
médecin était menacé avec une arme pour
un rendez-vous des faits qui ont amené
le Conseil de l'Ordre à se rapprocher de
la préfète et du procureur une ligne
téléphonique va être mise en place si
les médecins appellent en cas
d'agression ils seront géolocalisés ça
va pas tout régler mais c'est quand même
une sécurité pour eux et puis un message
aussi pour la population en disant que
le médecin doit être protégé doit être
respectée c'est pas juste un quelqu'un
qui va donner un arrêt de travail et
c'est quelqu'un qui est là pour vous
soigner qui est là pour vous prendre en
charge qui est là pour veiller sur vous
et c'est important pour une société que
les médecins soient respectés autrement
voilà au devant de graves problèmes
lors de sa garde à vue l'agresseur a
reconnu l'effet inconnu des services de
police et de justice il sera jugé en
janvier prochain